warning fiercely caffeinated highly
addictive world's strongest cold today
we found eight people who have a death
wish
world's strongest coffee
that's totally bull are you gonna wish
you died or it's what's gonna make you
guys are they implying it's enough
caffeine to kill you just how strong is
this coffee we took one milligram of
caffeine and substituted it for 1 tbsp
of death wish grounds so you can
actually see it there is oats
you can try all you want you're not
gonna make me afraid of beans I hate
coffee at the end I like sugar milk go
on the taste town oh wow this is amazing
just tastes like coffee notes of bone
and wood hell fire sales blood so that's
what that taste is it's Viking blood Wow
Wow like I can I feel like I'm like like
all my senses are like elevated right
now I'm drinking it without milk and I
can trick this whole Cup my heart is
definitely beating really fast I know I
would wish death coffee on anybody oh is
this gonna give us diarrhea I'm home
after work after having two cups of it
that felt a lot of energy running
through my hands I'm here in the
bathroom things are moving along really
well and currently it's around midnight
and he cannot fall asleep I usually like
me two or three cups of coffee to even
really feel it I'm definitely awake more
Deathwish Coffee please
now how many times like to say it